what was it like working with Stephen
Hawking on this particular uh problem
because it's kind of a whole journey
right well you know I I I I love the guy
I he's so
passionate about
physics
uh he just
yeah his
his Oneness with
the problem and the I mean it's
so his mind is all occupied by the world
that's uh yeah well let me tell you
there's a lot of other things with his
illness and with his celebrity and yeah
a lot of other things
a lot of distractions pulling at us uh
at his mind he's still there that's
right I remember him turning down
tea with Lady Gaga so we could spend
another hour on our paper
that my friend's dedication what did you
learn about physics what did you learn
about life from having worked uh with
Stephen Hawking well he was one of my
great teachers of course he's he's older
than me and I was I was reading his um
his textbooks in in um
in graduate school and um
uh you know I learned a lot about uh
relativity from him I learned about
passion for a problem I I learned about
um
not caring what other
people think you know I mean physics
isn't
interesting culture even if you make a
great discovery
like Walking Dead
people don't believe everything you say
in fact people love to disagree
it's it's a it's a a culture that
cherishes disagreement and and so you
know he kept ahead with what he believed
in and sometimes he was right and
sometimes he was wrong do you feel
pressure from the community so for
example with string theory
it was very popular for a time there's a
bit of criticism or is less popular now
do you feel the forces of the community
as it moves in and out of different
fields or do you try to stay like how
difficult is it to stay intellectually
and mathematically independent from the
community
personally
uh I'm lucky
I'm well equipped for that
I when I
started out in graduate school the
problem of quantum gravity was
not considered interesting
he still did it anyway I still did it
anyway I I'm a little bit of a
contrarian I guess and I think that has
served me well
um
and uh
people are always sort of disagreeing
with me
and they're usually right but I'm right
enough
and like you said the contradiction
ultimately paves the path of discovery